où est l'équipage je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas je suis là avec toi chaque équipage une
minute je
tue tous tes amis une minute où
est ton équipage je ne
sais pas je suis le
capitaine je vais tirer sur quelqu'un tirer  moi, hé,
regarde-moi, bien sûr, regarde-moi,
je suis le capitaine,
maintenant un cargo américain a été détourné, des
hommes armés et ont pris le capitaine en
otage. L'équipe SEAL Six à l'arrivée se détend quand nous serons payés,
tout ira bien, la Marine
ne va pas  pour te laisser gagner, ils
préféreraient couler ce
bateau tu viens avec nous Je veux 10 millions de dollars,
n'y entre pas, je dois le faire descendre
du navire maintenant comme
ça J'ai besoin de viser la cible pour Red pas de
tir, nous perdons cela,
exécutez-vous  Vous aviez un plan pour prendre mon
vaisseau et cela n'a pas fonctionné, alors vous avez
pensé que vous pourriez
m'abattre,
descendre [Musique], le capitaine Phillips, à la fin du PG-13 dans
les cinémas et en IMAX le 11 octobre.